and so I've been quite interested as as
you just heard in cortical basal ganglia
connectivity and more recently we've
been looking we've branched beyond just
the cortical basal ganglia connectivity
but to also critical critical
connectivity and one of our interests
the driving interests have always been
to understand better the circuits that
underline underlying motivation and
cognitive behaviors and so even though I
worked in Parkinson's disease it always
was with an idea of the non motor
aspects of Parkinson's disease because
as you probably know Parkinson's is not
only a motor disease but also affects
mental health in many different ways
and so the idea though that has driven a
lot of my work is trying to think about
the brain in across different kinds of
networks we have a sense or a tendency
to clump lots of different functions
together and I do too but I've been
quite interested for quite some time is
in understanding in particular how the
reward and motivation systems interact
with the cognitive systems and this
started in the basal ganglia for me
because of course the basal ganglia has
always been divided into these three
areas cognitive limbic and and motor and
yet when we behave in the world
we don't just tap into one and up the
other so our interest has very much been
driven by this idea of where the
connections across these circuits go and
so just to start this is just a snapshot
of various parts of cortex and an
striatum and basal ganglia and the
functions that we pin on those based on
a collection at lots of different
studies awake behaving primate
physiology studies human imaging studies
and so on and of course each area is its
own area of research and
I'm just giving you a sound bite of some
of the things that people link to these
so the vmPFC is important in choose
chosen value the orbital prefrontal
cortex links stimuli to their values
goal directed behaviors is the focus of
the research in that region the dorsal
anterior single just does does just
about everything so but I think a
guiding action switching is one of the
main components that people think about
the dorsal lateral the ventral lateral
prefrontal cortex are involved in
cognitive control and attentional
elements and we know we always link the
ventral striatum with reward and
motivation and the dorsal rostro
striatum with cognitive control so these
are kind of the areas that we think
about in terms of what functions they
have and of course all of these areas
are linked to abnormalities in many
different psychiatric diseases in
particular OCD depression schizophrenia
addiction PTSD etc and in fact if you
drill down to imaging studies and white
matter studies of these diseases the the
imaging studies will always give you a
collection of these areas that are
abnormal or changes and as I said I
think that this is just an example of
how we actually think about the brain
these are resting state networks that
have been described the well-known
default network and parcel aiding out
the cortical networks into these large
areas which are sort of data driven
networks which are then lumped together
in particular function but there are
large regions and then likewise the
cortical basal ganglia system has always
also been thought about as being
separate and segregated with the limbic
and the cognitive areas linked to
specific cortical regions and not on
here the motor areas which of course
have their own set of connections so
we've been interested as I mentioned is
you know how do you really go from being
hungry to wanting a pizza to thinking
about where you're going to get the
pizza to actually
of getting the pizza pizza all of which
is going on in your head it's kind of
the same time and some time ago we
published a paper that's and I'm not
going to go into this now but basically
it was it was demonstrated that one way
in which the limbic components of the
basal ganglia can influence the more
dorsal cognitive and motor components of
the basal ganglia is through these
connections through the substantia [ __ ]
in the dopamine neurons where the limbic
areas project to in region that projects
back up to more dorsal area of the
striatum and through this series of
loops there's spirals the more limbic
regions or the motivational regions can
influence the more cognitive and motor
regions and that subsequently has been
demonstrated a number of different
behavioral studies to exist by other
lambs but we've now been focused on two
things one is this is assuming that the
cortical striatal connection is fairly
straightforward and topographic but our
one some of our recent work more recent
work has demonstrated well maybe that's
not entirely the case maybe there's
actually integration going across these
net these functional regions within the
striatum and in addition we've also been
interested in regions of cortex that
crosstalk between these areas and you
probably are aware that there's a
growing interest now in how those broad
cortical networks that I just showed you
before are actually connected with each
other so we have these broad distributed
networks that have some kind of function
but how do they actually talk to each
other and what idea is that there's
there exists hubs which is kind of taken
from the graph theory ideas that that
really integrate and distribute the
information across these networks so
what we were interested in is how do we
actually demonstrate some of these
things from an anatomical perspective
the other area I want to talk about is
the white matter the white matter which
matters and we've known about
connections
the white matter you know for hundreds
of years right not hundreds but you know
quite a while but the information
between white matter or the interest in
white matter really got dropped for
decades until diffusion imaging came
along which was actually really
beautifully demonstrated so many
pathways and just to give you an idea of
the this is just a graph over the last
five years of white matter papers that
have come out I mean there's just this
huge and and that's not surprising to
you I'm sure and so this is just showing
you very briefly three pathways which
I'm going to talk a little bit about the
corpus callosum the cingulum bundle and
the internal capsule our areas that have
really captured many people's attention
especially because of the FA changes in
a number of diseases and over here I
just have a series of mental health
diseases that have focused on the white
matter and you know part of this
literature that has extended so much so
what I'd like to do then today is kind
of it's divided into two parts one is
the you know connections between regions
gray matter and regions and white matter
and so just sort of briefly we work in
the non-human primate and we use really
standard very old traditional techniques
there's nothing with weighing about what
we do they're just tracer injections
that we've been doing for you know again
decades hate to say that but it's true
and so here you have a monkey in a brain
and here you can see the fibers and you
have just visualized those fibers coming
up from an injection site and the goal
here is how do we go from the precision
of the anatomy that we can see to the
indirect methods that we have of looking
at connectivity both using diffusion
imaging both but also functional MRI how
do we translate from this to this and
then how do we actually back translate
to a rodent and because I know there's a
great interest here in the marmoset also
obviously announced an
model and so how do we take what we know
here and come in both directions and the
nonhuman old-world primate is a really
good translational piece to to go in
both directions and then taking what we
know from these areas of course drilling
down to understand disease okay so just
a couple slides on methods so here's an
injection site here's a coronal section
of the non-human primate brain you can
kind of see the striatum here it's not
well it's not counter stained you just
see the injection you can see the
beautiful pathway that's coming out the
fibers that are coming out from that
injection site which is blown up here in
addition this particular tracer type
goes gives you both anterior and
retrograde so here you can see the nice
labeled patches in the striatum and also
the labeled cells in various parts of
cortex so some of the tracers are unique
to be anterior great some are unique to
be retrograde and some are both and this
is just to give you an idea of our
objection sites in in cortex in the
prefrontal cortex and you can see we've
pretty much covered most orbital and
most of the medial the ventral medial
the interior cingulate the dorsal medial
and much of the lateral cortex so we
really have injection sites throughout
there so we can really understand how
this system how the organization works
and then what we do is with each one of
these injection sites we can outline the
pathways and here's an injection site
with the pathways you'll see a little
bit more just later so these are the
white matter pathways and the terminal
fields so for each one of these
injection sites we can map out the
complete projection and their white
matter pathways and how they get to
where they're going and then we can
combine them again in a 3d model and so
this is used this as would be too
complicated to do more but this is just
showing you three different injection
sites and three different colors and so
that we can
no I guess the light is shining on this
we can't see it that well but what you
can then do is take all of these
injection sites and compare the white
matter pathways with each other and
understand their organization and you
can understand the organization of the
terminal fields with each other so so
just as just outlining what we're going
to be doing so we take the Anatomy
studies and we determine the location of
the hubs and the distribution of those
in the pathways the white matter
pathways in the monkey and then we can
see the analogous region in the monkey
diffusion MRI so along with our
collaborators that Martino Center we
have image many of these monkeys they're
about 15 of those that have a
high-resolution diffusion MRI so that we
can actually compare that to to our
anatomical pathways to the diffusion so
you can really see which you know what
is actually a technical issue and what
is a real pathway in the diffusion and
then we can translate that to the human
both diffusion MRI and then we're also
working with colleagues looking at the
functional MRI to understand those
connectivity patterns that we see in
humans we're also using tracers and I'll
show you a little bit about that to
understand the rodent brain to again
identify the homologous regions that
might be hubs or and their pathways to
get in probe that system in more detail
and then finally we can compare a
disease with healthy control subjects to
think about where those disease
connections are abnormal and how we
might probe them for use them for
targeting so I'm going to start first
with the with the cortical basal ganglia
system and again this is just what you
see up on the top are examples of one
injection site in the vmPFC ofc and
dorsal anterior cingulate and what you
can see is their projection from each of
these and I picked them specifically to
show that they're somewhat separate from
each other however you saw how many
injections we have in each of those
areas so when you combine those areas
without overlapping another area right
so all of them have to be within say the
vmPFC and not the O of C and within the
ozium etc etc what you end up is with
obviously a much more a much larger and
broader projection region so this is
vmPFC this is vmPFC plus ofc and and
just the dorsal anterior cingulate and
the reason this is separate is that one
of our findings interestingly is that
all cortical areas are not created equal
in terms of how they project to the
striatum and even though there's a
topography to this which you can see
here the dorsal anterior cingulate is a
kind of special region because even with
the same relative size of the injection
site it seems to impact on a larger area
of Australia 'tom than most other
cortical regions and you can see that
here if you put them all together you
get a picture that looks something like
this within the striatum now if you
think to you think about what people
thought think about is the ventral
striatum that's the area that's
associated with reward and motivation
and usually what you'll do is you'll
divide it right here something like this
this is usually your typical ventral
striatum however there's not one of
these projections that's limited to that
area so right away you can see the
schematics that we have come to use all
all the time
may not be as precise as we would like
especially if you're looking at imaging
studies so if you find an area that is
responding to some kind of reward and
you find that area up here well you
could probably still safe in the ventral
striatum even though it's not ventral
but if you define the ventral striatum
by virtue of its inputs from some of
these regions that are associated with
emotion then it is well within that
and so you might start thinking about
how you put your scenes into an area to
probe it and also how you analyze those
so again this is putting them together
and what the other point that's
important here is that based on this you
can see that the striatum and we've now
validated that with some collaborators
that it's very similar in the human that
twenty five twenty to twenty five
percent to the striatum the whole
striatum is occupied by this sort of
limbic Eeyore motion reward area so
that's a very large area and also you
can see this is rendered in 3d and you
can see that each area although
topographically organized there are lots
of little spots in there in which
there's a convergence of various kinds
of inputs so what is what is that
convergence look like if you add the
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex you
have a similar kind of light I added it
in blue just so that you could see the
differences between there but you again
you see that things are very very mixed
in and then we went back translated
again and so what does this look like in
the rodent and we found that in fact the
road and has a very very similar kind of
organization that is there is a
topography but from ILO FCPS PL and
anterior cingulate you still see this
kind of a mixture so there's topography
but within that topography there clearly
areas in which regions converge and it's
those areas that may be interesting to
probe for specific kinds of behaviors
rather than just simply say were we're
now in the limbic versus Dorse cognitive
system with rah
bruno ever back at nih we then looked at
a probabilistic map created a
probabilistic map of all of our
injections actually at the time that
were the relatively much fewer than we
have now so going to redo this map but
basically what we found was that this
region right about here is an area that
gets input from all five of those areas
that was just talking about vmPFC ofc
dorsal lateral ventral lateral
to your cingulate and so we think that
this could be right a kind of a hub
because these are areas that are coming
together that not are not normally part
of the same the same the same network we
also had a retrograde tracer it just so
happened in this region up here and we
had four out of the five and fifth one
that was not included with the vmPFC
here are the cell counts that we see
illogically counted those cells you can
see that the EM PFC is pretty much left
out but orbital ventral lateral dorsal
lateral anterior cingulate are all there
but in addition we had caudal cingulate
cortex and a part of parietal cortex and
this is an area in parietal cortex that
is a perceptual area and an area event
is actually activated when a addicted
individual is in a scanner and shown
drug queues and and start to crave so
this is a perceptual area that you know
is very into be linked to many things of
course but addiction is one of them and
so on young child in the lab then did an
analysis of the inputs in the striatum
this is all based on the striatal
anatomy where she saw that here in this
region as we might have predicted using
anterior grade projections to the
striatum a hot spot in that area and
then she probed that area using
resting-state MRI in the human here and
then controlled just lateral to a little
bit ventral to that seed and found that
this seed very much was very similar to
the input she got from here which
included the area of parietal dorsal
lateral prefrontal ventral lateral
prefrontal cortex and she also got some
orbital in this and the anterior
cingulate whereas the seed just placed a
little bit lateral and a little bent row
got a much more limited input so these
are ways in which we're thinking that we
can
use these kinds of maps to go back into
into the imaging world and probe those
networks more specifically again back
translating is going back to the rodent
we want to ask the question should we
start thinking about reparse elating out
the rodent striatum and so Sarah
Helen Brunner in our lab then came up
with a very clever idea of starting with
the homologous regions that we know are
homologous across species so we know
that the amygdala is the amygdala in the
human monkey and in the rodent
we know that the shell of the nucleus
accumbens we can identify it over all
three species and we know that we all
have a hippocampus so she asked the
question let's outline those areas in
the striatum so this is a shell this is
the projection region from the
hippocampus and this is the projection
region from the amygdala in the rodent
and in the monkey okay and right away
you can see that there is a really nice
homology they're kind of positioned in
very very similar places what does that
mean what that means is that we can now
ask what projects to those regions what
projects specifically to those regions
what projects partly to them and partly
outside of those regions and what is the
interaction between areas that project
to these regions and outside that area
so so starting with il in area 25 she
found that they mainly occupy this this
whole region which is pretty much
outlined in the amygdala projection area
and then she found that PL in area 32
partly project there but also partly
outside of it and area 24 and anterior
cingulate in the rodent is a problem so
that's something that we are starting to
think about how we divide the rodent and
the human cingulate in more detail and
the same thing was true of orbital
cortex nobody really had a good idea the
homology is between the two and using
this method you can
nicely see that the areas that are
occupied by MO and media orbital and
what's called VL vo vo hello in the rep
and the central ladder orbital in the
monkey have very similar positions so
again using this kind of method we can
start thinking about how we might divide
up the rodent and then based on that
there two things take-home messages here
in the slide the first is that you can
see the the color coding here you know
have some real similarities which is
really interesting and you can see that
I showed you that the ventral part of
the medial the sort of limbic II reward
motivation region crawls up the medial
part of the caudate and you can see it
does the same thing in the rodents when
we compare them in this way the orbital
areas occupy a similar place and and we
have some of the anterior cingulate also
in orbital in the same areas more
laterally the other take-home message is
that each of these areas don't get input
from one region again similar to what we
saw in the monkey so what's in large
letters are the main inputs and then the
smaller letters are also inputs but or
not the not the big dense inputs so
again I think coming back to this where
there's a lot of work we're still doing
on this one thing one thing that we've
realized is the PL in in the rodent our
new data as well as the date of Greg
Kirk who is a collaborator of ours in in
the county in our County grant have done
nning to think about the PL is a very
complicated area and probably should be
divided into four regions certainly a
rostral in a caudal region and if we do
that my guess is and we're thinking that
the PL part the Rosso PL will be more
similar to area 32 and that the caudal
might have elements of anterior
cingulate in the monkey so let me switch
now to the
to the cortex and I so again if we think
about regions the cortex is this reward
motivation region that we most people
will agree vmPFC and and OSE are part of
there's a cognitive area with dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex and ventral
lateral prefrontal big part of and
there's a motor area and yet they're
regions like the dorsal anterior
cingulate in VL and dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex and probably pre pre
SMA that really have a foot in more than
one of these networks and so what we're
going to do what I'm going to do now is
just focus on the dorsal anterior
cingulate cortex I'm going to play this
very brief movie and what this is going
to show you is so remember I mentioned
that we can look at the projections from
these different areas of cortex to the
cortex so these are some of the
injection sites together only a few we
have just started this project we have
many more to go through but these are
the injection sites and vmPFC orbital
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex ventral
lateral prefrontal cortex etc anterior
cingulate and what you're going to do
and also the amygdala and so what you're
going to do now is see the projections
which are indicated by little
stippling from each of these injection
sites and what you first noticed that
they pretty much stay in their own area
but many of them spread there's
anteriors think you can see how spread
out that is from this one VL PFC you can
see it also spreads dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex and and then the
amygdala and so taken from this we
started a look at these maps and asked
questions where do a lot of these
projections come together and the one
that we started with is an area in the
anterior cingulate in this region of the
anterior cingulate and so if you look at
the literature of the many anatomist
outstanding animus then have identified
the input
to the anterior seeing is there's a
little schematic of the anterior
cingulate which this is kind of off it
should be over here but it's also weird
but okay these are all the areas based
on the anatomical maps that have already
been done that project to the anterior
cingulate so there's really quite a
collection of regions that have been
shown to project there but but they can
project in two ways and then we know
from the literature actually there's a
kind of a gradient from there's more
limbic reward regions through
associative through motor regions that
go in from the ventral caudal moving in
this direction back dorsal and caudal so
ventral moving in that direction so the
other possibility which is what we
wanted to ask is whether there are areas
within that gradient that stand out that
are anomalies with from that that
gradient and Wei Tang in the lab has
been exploring that here are injection
sites that we have in the anterior sink
this is white matter so the cortex would
be surrounding this just so you can see
the injection site and she's been
exploring that and remember that's the
map we've seen from all the inputs from
the literature and here are injection
sites we've number two one two three
four five six to go around in this
manner and ask the question whether or
not this any of these injection sites
stand out as outside this gradient so we
have a lot of work to do on this but
basically the three on the bottom this
is the pattern of projections laid on to
all the projections that have been shown
in the literature again which we can
validate that we see all those
projections and in red for each of these
indicates 75% of the projections come
from these regions to that injection so
here's injection one seventy-five
percent of that comes from these areas
in red and you can see there's a very
there's a big similarity between these
there
in this more rostral and dorsal one you
start to pull in a few other regions but
it's pretty much reward motivation kind
of related and then if you look at the
four five six
Goodin you see that you're starting to
pull in more and this air this one is
much more cognitive and motor air
related premotor related this is what we
have identified right now you can see
that many more branches are labeled in
this than in the others and picking up
areas that are not necessarily
represented in the others and this is
the region that we now believe may serve
as a hub and way is now drilling down
even further we have a few injection
sites flanking this to actually make
sure that this is true but it is an area
that we find in terms of functional
imaging that seems to be very commonly
seen in a number of diseases if you look
at the homologies across species she
started to look using on monkey
diffusion tractography to ask the
question where do the streamlines most
converge and again she's getting a
pattern very similar to what we see in
the in the in the anatomy in terms of
the strengths of the inputs to that area
and then finally looking using the
connectome data we find an area very
similar to what we see in the monkey in
this region of the anterior cingulate
and unlike the monkey we see also an
area more caudally but we find a region
in in this rostral part again an area
that's been demonstrated to be activated
in a number of diseases with beijing lu
at the martinez he's also now started to
probe this using resting state again by
very precisely feeding the regions now
should project there and again having a
very nice
correspondence with this region in the
dorsal anterior cingulate so just in
summary of this part of the top
I just wanted to summarize here by
saying this cross talk between reward
and cognitive control networks that we
see in both the striatal and in cortical
regions in particular I showed you the
dorsal anterior cingulate and we think
that these areas might be specifically
important for changing or adapting
behaviors appropriately the hope is that
in a rodent model or in preps in the
marmoset one could then identify some of
these areas of probe more deeply as to
what kind of the microcircuitry that
underlies these complex inputs in these
regions and how they may behave may be
manipulated in behaviors and again
thinking about them as possible
therapeutic targets and already
mentioned that point the one is switched
now for the last 20 minutes or so to the
white matter of pathways and those three
I'm going to kind of touch on a beat
most about the interior seeing the
anterior limb of the internal capsule
but also work we've done on the cingulum
bundle on the corpus callosum and so in
these areas as I mentioned are the ones
that are most prominently that people
find abnormalities in many of the
psychiatric diseases so what we had done
Julie Lehman in the lab we first
actually started this by using injection
sites and just probing the ventral
surface of the brain the ventral medial
prefrontal cortex in the orbital cortex
and just asked the question how do
fibers get to where they're going and is
there an organization to this and so
what we found was in fact there are a
number of points that we found very
consistent across the white matter
pathways and you'll see this again but
the white matter comes
out of a portable region they divide
into various specific bundles that carry
specific information and then travel to
their targets and I don't want to go
through all of this it's very confusing
but I do it a little movie to show you
to give you some perspective that these
areas if you do these injections across
the ventral surface they have a
particular projection organization so
this is the unsent of fasciculus they
come over and cross the corpus callosum
you can see they're ordered they go
through the cingulum bundle and so you
can see the corpus callosum has a
specific organization to it the internal
capsule again you can see the specific
organization of ventral to dorsal
organization and then this is going to
just show you the four perspectives
that's the anterior and anterior
commissure
so in these fibers are also are
descending into the brainstem but what
the take-home message here is that these
three different colors are representing
three different pathways that are not
that injection sites that are not that
far apart and yet they have a very
specific organization and so to be clear
about that here the injection sites
there were four of them four examples of
them and what you can see is in the
internal capsule we can tell how they
enter the internal capsule so if you're
in this very medial part you enter from
the ventral surface if you're more
lateral you actually enter from the
dorsal surface so you're entering the
capsule in a different way and then you
live in the capsule in a different way
so if you are more medial you live
ventral if you're more lateral you you
live more dorsal and all that is telling
us is that there are rules in which
fibers get to where they're going and
how they are positioned within a pathway
and so why is that interesting because
when you look at FA values for example
in disease changes in them they're never
threw out a whole pathway but they're
always spotty so the question is what is
spots represent and what we're hoping
for is to be able to be more precise
about abnormalities white matter
abnormalities in terms of what kinds of
connections are we're talking about and
so these are photomicrographs showing
you the medial orbital for fibers with
embedded in the internal anterior
commissure and beneath it and the more
dorsal ones and from the orbital and
then the more lateral ones and so then I
had made a trip to Oxford and I gave a
talk and I was really excited to meet
Tim Behrens and the Oxford group and
from that came a great collaboration in
which we started to ask the question
well can we see these things using
diffusion imaging and in fact we could
see many of these things using diffusion
imaging so this is the monkey histology
the monkey model that I just showed you
based on the histology monkey diffusion
in a different monkey is not the same
and human and we saw many of the same
features but some were not able to see
so so I came back and we started we
continued that collaboration but then I
had the fortune to also be a visitor at
the Martino's and met Anastasia and that
I never can say you're Liz right right
but yeah I'm Becky I can say it when I'm
not in front of a people but Anna that's
true and so she and I have now been also
exploring this in detail and so what
we've done is we started to image some
of our animals so this is where we now
have imaging in the same animal as as we
have the injection but what I want to
talk about first before I get to that
because this is really a key is that
what you know from the pathways here's
this beautiful pathway I showed you
before it's coming from here this is the
injection that's coming from the ventral
part this injection is coming from the
lateral
and this is coming from the dorsal and
these are the streamline this is the I'm
sorry not streamline these are actually
the axons so these exons are here and
these exons are coming in here and these
exponents are coming up and so what you
can do is you can very precisely see
them and you can very precisely draw
them and then you can put them in a 3d
model and how they get to where they're
going really depends of course on how
they leave the injection site so what we
found was that when they come down
here's what we're calling it a [ __ ] it's
a stop that comes down it divides into
three things the stock does not really
contain a lot of cortical cortical
fibers they're kind of peeling off what
the stock contains is and when they
divide is the corpus callosum striatal
fibers and capsule fibers so
internal-external extreme capsules and
all of these will show that division and
the reason I'm paying a little bit of
attention to this is that this is one
place that diffusion goes go can go
wrong so I'm going to first show you the
internal capsule and to show you all of
our injections again what you can see is
this is when you saw before but now
there are many other regions there's the
orbital the anterior cingulate ventral
lateral prefrontal cortex and the dorsal
lateral prefrontal cortex and what you
can see is that again as I mentioned for
the pathways I showed you before they're
very well organized you see a nice
typography so we wanted to outline that
topography in more detail but first we
had to make sure that we could take our
diffusion our Anatomy into the diffusion
so here's an injection site here's an
animal that have this is the same animal
so it's diffusion in same animal you see
the injection site beautiful injection
site you see the streamlines shooting
out the exon shooting out the stream
lines shooting out corpus callosum
corpus callosum really really nice
however
what you can see down here is where
diffusion is not replicating correctly
and you have see false positives so you
see the false positive here in the
fornix and there are a number of other
areas that have four it's positive so we
asked first can diffusion divided into
these three areas the way we see it in
the actual tissue and so what we found
and this is on this work has also been
helped by giorgia a graduate student of
Anastasius in mine and so what we see is
that you can identify the correct
pathway and you can identify an
incorrect stream line yellow is correct
and the blue is an incorrect stream line
and once you can do that and you
understand where they go off you can
start to do that in the human and the
reason it's going off here is what
happens is for some reason we find that
the stream line also goes down since and
a false positive and I don't want to go
into the details into the striatum and
so here you can see in a human once you
know that you know the one to follow so
in this case you can see that this is a
stream line that's correct it's coming
down it's going to this is going to
divide into the internal council and
into the extreme capsules but this one
is incorrect this blue one and so using
this kind and here's it is in 3d here's
the correct one here's an incorrect one
so using this kind of information we can
now ask the question how is the internal
capsule organized how is it organized
of course we first identified in the in
the anatomy and the human in the monkey
in the diffusion in the in the monkey
and then in the human by eliminating the
false positives and so this is just
illustrating how well we can replicate
it this is again based on the anatomy
the nice typography it's the
dorsal-ventral rule I won't go through
all the rules but there's if your dorsal
you'll be dorsal in the internal capsule
middle and ventral and you have that
same organization within the internal
council you see the diffusion gives us
the same pattern in the monkey and the
same pattern in the human you do if the
false positive but we know this one is
probably the correct one so again we can
replicate that in the human
understanding that and then we can go
back and actually look at individual
cases in using the connectome and you
can see that in individual cases they're
located a little bit different places
but you can see the pattern is similar
throughout the human so what does that
mean so this is how the anterior limb of
the internal capsule has been organized
you have a dorsal ventral a medial
lateral rule there's some overlap given
the compression of the capsule but by
doing this we have some good deal here
now of which fibers are actually passing
through these regions we can make an FA
map which we did this is a heat map and
run statistics on the different
components and see that each of these
areas this is a normal brain actually
are statistically significantly
different that the DFA values to these
areas that carry these fibers are
different and then with Mary Phillips
also part of our contest she then probed
this using our map and asked the
question are the abnormalities that we
see in the chief sees and bipolar
disorder patients in the anterior limit
the internal capsule can they be
associated with a specific set of
pathways and indeed she did find there
was a significant difference between the
FA values specifically in regions that
carry the VL t FC fibers and that was
very exciting for her because she had
already shown in a number of other
situations another number of other
papers the activity in the VL PFC was
abnormal in the in the VL PFC and this
is a map that was generated by another
collaborator rita goldstein using
cocaine addicted individuals and looking
at their fa map and again we haven't
really analyzed this so this is very
very preliminary but the idea again is
this is a typical map you might see of
fa changes in disease whereas they
mentioned you know you have a very
spotty organization and looking at this
one might say and again we haven't
really explored this so this is
something that's just super preliminary
but if you look at this you might say
well just maybe the vmPFC fibers there
may not be any abnormalities there but
in the in there connections but we we
could start to look closer at the VLPs
see the DFC dorsal anterior see and the
ofc fibers so these are just ways in
which we can use these maps so just an
example - now look at at diseases the
other use of this of course is looking
at deep brain stimulation and so we've
been also working with a number of
groups looking at the brain stimulation
and here the electrodes for the deep
brain stimulation of the of the internal
capsule so here are the four electrodes
this is for the intern interior
electrodes for the ventral striatum
again four contact points and the helenm
a burg electrode sites for the
depression and for the deep brain
stimulation for Parkinson's disease and
for OCD in the STM so I want to just
kind of mention a few of these ways of
looking at these as well
so for the deep brain stimulation in the
internal capsule you can see in our
model we can put the electrode in a
model of these fiber pathways that I
just showed you and start to ask
questions about when you stimulate each
of these contacts which fibers which
connections are you likely to be
activating and then what we've been
doing is
taking patients down have the electrodes
implanted and merging a CT scan that
identifies the contents with their MRI
scan a high-resolution structural MRI
and a diffusion MRI and then place seeds
in the diffusion we're merging those
images place these in the internal
capsule at the contact sites and ask
questions about given the parameters
that they are being simulated and the
particular context they are using in
that individual can we identify the
likely pathways that are going to be
activated and what we found is then
they're just beginning to break the
blind of this particular study so I
don't really have the results but what
we do know and this makes complete sense
in terms of the anatomy which was that
the lower the contact was in the more
caudal it was the more anxiety was
produced in the patient and so they you
know didn't use that contact but
simulated a more and more dorsal one and
when we looked at the patient's outcomes
in terms of their imaging we found that
indeed the lower more caudal contacts
were ones that were projecting both to
partly through the hypothalamus and to
enter the amygdala so when we move those
electrodes the contacts of simulation
more dorsally and then in subsequent
patients a little bit more Rost early we
were able to get a better outcome so
this is how the anatomy can help inform
these kinds of therapeutic targets and
actually change them so again just not
to focus only on the human in the monkey
we've also started to probe what is the
internal capsule look like in the rodent
again because the internal capsule had
not been described very well in the
rodent in fact the internal capsule in
the rodent is usually considered after
the anterior commissure and thus and the
fascicles that run through the striatum
who are not really oregon i
identified in an organized way and
without going through a lot of the
detail what we found was these fascicles
within the stratum of the rodents are in
part the internal capsule the anterior
limb of the internal capsule so these
are the fibers that are going from the
areas of cortex to the thalamus and what
we found also is that they're organized
in a very similar manner as we see in
the in the in the monkey and so what
that allows you to do so there's a nice
typography both in the rostral areas
where there isn't a clear internal
capsule as well as in the more caudal
areas where there are and what that
allows us to do then in the rodent is be
more precise if somebody is trying to
wants to do a simulation experiment now
we have an idea about what fibers
they're going to be simulating if you're
doing a lesion experiment you want to be
careful because you're not only
lesioning you know it depends on the
kind of lesion but you might want to be
careful because there may be fibers that
are actually not part of the striatum
that you're affecting and it also allows
us to for those that are doing cell
slice preparation and the wanting to
capture the cortical thalamic
projections they now pan we now can in
our 3d model provide the the angle that
is best suited for developing that so
there are a lot of ways that we can use
now the rodent model to explore things
that we weren't able to before just
knowing where those fibers are going the
other two pathways that I'm going to
briefly talk about is the cingulum
bundle and the corpus callosum
so the cingulum bundle is an interesting
bundle and we think about the cingulum
bundle
it's just connecting the cingulate
cortex and we know that fibers run into
in the cingulum bundle that connect to
the cingulate cortex we don't usually
think of the cingulum bundle as a
highway that fibers might use that have
nothing to do with the cingulate
or texts but in fact that's what we
found we found fibers from the ventral
for example from ventral medial
prefrontal cortex might hop on the
cingulum bundle and then just hop off at
the dorsal medial prefrontal cortex or
the dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex and
just use it as a as a pathway and so
that's quite interesting again in terms
of thinking about when we look at
abnormalities in the cingulum bundle
it's one of the most prominent fiber
bundles that we see fa changes in again
where they are within the bundle is
important in identifying what
connectivity profiles you're looking at
in terms of where changes might be made
and so this is a paper by Sarah again
who identified the areas of the cingulum
bundle and what goes through them and so
they're color-coded here in green but
the main thing that I want to point out
is that this section this little pink
section here has a number of fibers that
are running through it they don't run
through it here or here and in
particular this region carries VL PFC of
fibers and lateral orbital fibers which
don't run through any of the other areas
and so we can make maps again of what
goes where and the important part of
this is again looking at therapeutic
targets over on these two of images
cingulotomy is as you probably know is
still a procedure that is often used for
treatment resistant depression and a
treatment resistant OCD and actually
they're carried out here at Mass General
primarily EMA desk and artha is one of
the main surgeons doing them and here's
you here you have an idea about where
the lesion is here's an older lesion
they change them a little bit but you
can see that the cingulotomy czar going
to include not only the cingulate cortex
but of course the cingulum bundle and
what we know is that this area is sort
of in between these two and the
interesting thing is
again we don't were starting to probe
this because now we are getting the
patient's images from individuals that
have had cingulotomy and so we want to
probe and ask the question whether or
not it's better to interrupt fibers in
this region that has the VL PFC and
orbital fibers or if you want to avoid
that region right so these are the kinds
of things we can now ask now that we
understand how these fibers come through
this area and again this is just some
preliminary work that we've started to
look at at one patient that does have a
cingulotomy lesion and you can see it
right here it's interrupting these
fibers and you can see it here it's
interrupting fibers from the caudal part
the last area I want to talk about is
the corpus callosum again a fiber
pathway we all know know very well we
all know that it connects the two
hemispheres and in fact for a long time
we've known actually the parts of it and
we've also known for a long time it's
functional organization really because
it's just connecting the two sides of
the hemisphere right right at that point
so if you're in order cortex you know
it's going to be carrying motor coal
fibers to the other side fairly
straightforward but this part carries
the prefrontal cortex and it's very
large because the genu you know comes
down is a very very large region and so
we asked the question how is this area
organized and you can see that we found
as I mentioned as you saw in a little
movie it's organized really really very
well and so we've been now looking at
many of our injections this is just the
kind of pretty picture of our injection
sites all the fibers funneling through
to the corpus callosum and to this part
because this is the area because when
you think about it all of the areas
before the corpus callosum have to
travel back cross and go forward again
so
in this region you have all of the
prefrontal fibers all kind of smashed
together but they're in a very thick
thick dorsal-ventral organization and so
you can see there is an organization to
this I don't know if you can see this
very well but again according to the
color coded according to cortical region
again another way to think about
abnormalities in disease
so in summary of this part I just wanted
to say that we have similar organization
through the anterior limb of the
internal capsule in the corpus callosum
and the rodent we can identify an
anterior limb in the rodent it has a
similar organization and we can segment
these big bundles according to specific
connections and we can use those to link
with disease which allows us to have a
better idea of how we target those
diseases but if you want to say that one
of the things that's driven this so far
really is the ability to use the anatomy
of the monkey to understand what we're
seeing in diffusion and on what we're
seeing in functional MRI and so again
just to end with the slide I started
with so we're using this very precise
ability to identify pathways and
connections to understand the human
brain to back translate to the rodent
and to the hopefully marmoset and to the
and to understand human disease in
target and with that I'd like to thank
the people that have really helped in
all of this these are some of the people
in the lab that I've identified with
their work in yellow are the members of
my Conti organization I want to
highlight Anastacio who's really been so
important in helping us think about the
diffusion and Tim Behrens and his group
as well and Haitian Lu who's really been
so helpful in thinking about functional
connectivity profiles so thank you very
much
[Applause]
well I think that understanding how
connectivity profiles in Iraq does help
us understand what parts meant it's a
two-way street
right so we all get information from
behavioral studies and how emotions are
garage and then we think about areas
that might be connected to develop those
kinds of behaviors so it certainly
drives my work and my guess is that
people who study those areas also think
about the structures that we find are
connected
right so when the different simulations
started it was assumed that you were
stimulating the help desk sorry that's
my timer it was assumed that you were
stimulating the gray matter you're
simulating the structure that you
thought was involved in whatever it was
but we now know stimuli parameters
people use it's mainly the white matter
it's mainly the myelinated fibers that
you're simulating of course you're
having an effect on the cells
immediately around there but you may
have simulating the white matter so in
Helens case so in Helens case she was
always stimulating the white matter that
was just adjacent to areas 25 and 32 so
it would have been the uncinate
fasciculus and now she is particularly
focused on the on the area that brings
uncinate fasciculus and the corpus close
to the ventral part of the corpus
closing together so yeah it's mainly the
white matter the single item is now
they're much more caudal and dorsal so
she's in the ventral part of the sub
genuine and the cingulotomy ZAR the
dorsal interiors to give it a more
causal and those are getting the
cingulate cortex and the cingulum bundle
they don't go quite to the midline which
is one of the things that we're
interested in seeing what is spared
because you they can't go to the midline
for safety reasons so you're always
going to be sparing some of those fibers
and one of the things we've been quite
interested in is understanding oh how
well and which ones are scared
right so so that's exactly what would be
of course important to probe in a rodent
or you know a marmoset model I think it
depends on what comes in to a given area
so the place that I had shown that
parietal cortex comes in and remember
there's you know both you know
transmitter systems there that are you
know modulating the behavior all the
time so that's an area that gets input
that particular one would get input from
vlp FC and ofc and uh FCN is important
so so we were thinking about it in terms
of being able to direct your attention
because you get this parietal cortical
input in dorsal lateral prefrontal
cortex to some very salient important
stimuli in which you have a particular
goal so that would involve the orbital
and in dorsal lateral and parietal
cortex and so one of the areas that we'd
be interested in for example is in
addicted individuals we know that as
people become more addicted and in
animals the activity moves pretty much
from the ventral parts of the striatum
to the more dorsal parts of the striatum
so one question one could ask then is is
this area along with its dopamine input
etc particularly important and sort of
stamping in those habits that are very
hard to break just an example of how
what one might think about the different
combinations of inputs that might come
in to different parts of the striatum
and so that's yeah so that's a really
interesting question I don't know but
what I do know is that the cortical
slamet cortical connection does have
that attribute so we we also looked at
that some time ago so the cortex
projects to the thalamus in a wider area
than thalamus projects to the cortex and
the lamo cortical projection is much
more precise so there is this shifting
that does occur and actually we were
surprised to find that it all actually
occurs in the same direction we're
thinking maybe it would currently
reverse direction but it doesn't what
we're doing now is looking at those
downstream projections from striatum to
pallidum Eltham actually to the ftn
because we want to ask a similar
question which is how is information to
the striatum transferred them to the
pallidum and that projection is very
topographic so once you have this
organization of convergence and
potential integration in the striatum
that whatever processing that's doing
comes down to the palin there's
something else going down there but that
is very topographic you don't have the
station so much from those pathways
until